KEEP AROUND.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT.
AFTER 18 YEARS OF WAR, HE WOULD
THINK THE UNITED STATES WOULD BE
WINDING DOWN IN THE GULF.
AT TIMES IT SEEMS TO BE WEAK ON
THE BRINK OF BOMBING IRAN.
WE ARE DOING IT PRIMARILY TO
PROTECT SAUDI ARABIA.
IN WASHINGTON, THE SAUDIS ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY CONSIDERED BY
BOTH PARTIES TO BE ONE OF OUR
CLOSEST ALLIES.
THE STRANGE THING IS,
SAUDI ARABIA HAS PART CLOSER
LINKS TO THE 9/11 ATTACKS THEN
SADDAM HUSSEIN EVER DID.
MUCH LESS, IRAN.
IRAN HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH 9/1
9/11.
SAUDI ARABIA MEANWHILE WAS IT SO
CONNECTED TO 9/11 AND THAT THE
FAMILIES OF MANY 9/11 VICTIMS
ARE SEEKING JUSTICE, PAYMENT, AS
RECOMPENSE FOR THE SAUDIS ROLE.
NO HOW EXACTLY DOES THE COUNTRY
AND THE GOVERNMENT GET TO
IGNORE THIS AND WHAT IS THE NATR
IGNORE THIS AND WHAT IS THE NATE
IGNORE THIS AND WHAT IS THE NATO
IGNORE THIS AND WHAT IS THE NATF
AMERICA'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
SAUDI ARABIA?
WE DECIDED TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK
AT THAT QUESTION.
HERE'S WHAT WE FOUND.
>> IN RESPONSE TO THE KING'S
REQUEST, THE PRESIDENT HAS
APPROVED THE DEPLOYMENT OF U.S.
FORCES PAID TO STICK IT OUT
WAS SECRETARY OF DEFENSE MARK
ESPER ANNOUNCING A DEPLOYMENT OF
TROOPS TO HELP OUR PARTNER IN
THE REGION.
NOT A LOT OF AMERICANS VIEW
SAUDI ARABIA AS AN ALLY.
CHRIS YANCEY, NEW YORK CITY
FARMING, LOST HIS FATHER ON
9/11.
>> I THINK YOU MAKE AND PEOPLE
SHOULD KNOW WHAT THE INVOLVEMENT
OF SAUDI 9/11 WAS BEFORE WE
COMMIT TO BEING THERE ALLY.
>> Tucker: HE'S 1 OF THOUSANDS
OF FAMILY MEMBERS OF 9/11
VICTIMS DOING SAUDI ARABIA.
THEIR LAWSUIT STATES THAT
SAUDI ARABIA KNOWINGLY PROVIDED
AL QAEDA WITH SUPPORTS,
FINANCING, AND RESOURCES THAT
WERE MATERIAL SUBSTANTIAL AND
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
SEPTEMBER 11TH ATTACKS.
>> FOR YEARS, SAUDI ARABIA
THROUGH ITS CHARITIES HAD BEEN
FUNNELING MONEY TO AL QAEDA TO
GET AHEAD IN SAUDI ARABIA TO
RISE IN THE GOVERNMENT YOU NEED
TO SHOW --
>> Tucker: A HEAVILY REDACTED
2012 REPORT SHOWS THAT SUPPORT
THE SAUDI OFFICIALS GAVE TO TWO
HIJACKERS.
THEY GAVE THE CHARCOAL AL QAEDA
MEMBERS ASSISTANCE AND DAILY
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING PROVIDING
MONEY AND HELPING THE HIJACKERS
GET FLYING LESSONS.
>> MANY SAUDI GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WERE IN COHORTS IF YOU
WILL WITH SEVERAL OF THE 9/11
HIJACKERS.
>> Tucker: IN A SWORN
DECLARATION IN 2017, RETIRED FBI
SPECIAL AGENT STEPHEN MOORE
STATED THAT THE HIJACKERS WOULD
HAVE HAD ZERO CHANCE FOR SUCCESS
WITHOUT A SUPPORT STRUCTURE
WAITING FOR THEM.
THE FAMILY STILL WANT MORE
INFORMATION DECLASSIFIED ABOUT
SAUDI INVOLVED AND THEN AND FEEL
AS IF THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT HAS
BETRAYED THEM.
ONE WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT THE
FBI WORKED FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NOT THE INTERESTS OF
SAUDI ARABIA.
>> Tucker: THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT REGION RECENTLY
STARTED STATE SECRETS IN
NATIONAL SECURITY REFUSING TO
DECLASSIFY 2012 FBI REPORT
THAT CONTAINS SAUDI TIES TO 9/11
HIJACKERS.
IN THAT SAME COURT FILING, THE
DOJ DECIDED IT WOULD ONLY
RELEASE THE NAME OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO DIRECTED TWO
SAUDI OFFICIALS TO HELP
HIJACKERS UNDER PROTECTIVE
ORDER.
>> THE OBSTACLES THE GOVERNMENT
HAS PUT UP JUST FOR THE TRUTH IS
VERY DISHEARTENING.
STEEL AND U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
NOT BEEN KEEN TO HOLD THE SAUDIS
TO
ACCOUNT IN THE WAKE OF 9/11.
SHORTLY AFTER THE 9/11 ATTACKS,
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION A LOT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED SAUDIS,
INCLUDING NUMBERS OF THE
BIN LADEN FAMILY TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY ON CHARTERED AIRPLANES
AND TWO YEARS AGO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CAUTIONED A
RETIRED FBI AGENT WHO WOULD BEEN
WORKING FOR THE 9/11 FAMILIES.
>> I COULDN'T BELIEVE MY FORMER
EMPLOYER WAS TELLING ME NOT TO
GIVE ASSISTANCE TO THE VICTIMS
OF 9/11.
TO ME IT WAS UNCONSCIONABLE AND
IT REALLY DISTURBED ME.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT, UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE ASKED THE FBI ABOUT KEN
WILLIAMS CLAIMED THAT HE WAS